build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
Creations from Everyday People this is
bdp build it Nick Cave makes these sound
suits out of materials like stuffed
animals sock monkeys and Beanie Babies
they're like wearable sculptures and he
has a YouTube channel full of videos of
people dancing in these
things for more rugged sculptures there
are these words made of welded chains
the Korean artist uses tightly knit
bicycle and steel chains to create the
figures and also to evoke the distraught
emotions that the pieces represent a
Memphis man built this homemade fire
breathing dragon on his front lawn it
has a chicken wire frame with red cotton
skin and there's a flamethrower mounted
inside the head and Cody koala found an
old Game Boy and turned it into a zombie
the feet are from an Iron Man figure the
hands from Iron Monger and the face face
is a printed piece of paper draw
Christian Wagner made this series of
Star Wars paintings for Acme archives
direct these close-ups of iconic helmets
from the films use reflection to capture
some of its most memorable scenes Laura
Zombie's grunge art style takes bright
color splattered watercolors and
transforms them into psychedelic works
of art like a sick Ronald McDonald and a
few depressed superheroes here's some
Twisted pop culture watercolors from
Wednesday wolf
finally Andre defus created some zombie
portraits of familiar faces like Batman
Ryu from Street Fighter and yeah there
he is Play It Anton norling has a bunch
of great video game metal covers where
he plays all the guitar parts as well as
the bassine here's the theme from
Bowser's Castle in Super Mario
World Super powerless combines 8bit
samples with modern pop music Here's
their cover of time is running out by
Muse featuring a bunch of great public
domain footage from old monster
movies time is running out he can't push
it on the ground he can't stop
SC dubstep and Mega Man 2 collide with
this remix from Donnie music best of all
you can download his albums for free
from his YouTube
channel
finally Keith Apper made this music
video about his beloved fictitious Sega
console the Dreamcast 2 because if they
do the
dream you know if true cuz if
they submit your own bdps at
facebook.com/vsaucegaming or as a
personal message here on YouTube and as
always thanks for
watching
h